- Des centaines de numéros
d'assurance maladie liés
à des rendez-vous
pour des vaccins contre
la COVID-19 se sont avérés
facilement accessibles
sur internet.
Et c'est un membre
de la communauté du Hackfest,
un groupe de personnes
intéressées par
la cybersécurité,
qui a fait la découverte.
Ces membres mettent
régulièrement la main
sur ce genre d'information,
comme l'explique
le co-fondateur Patrick Mathieu.
PATRICK MATHIEU, cofondateur
Hackfest Communication
- Nous, on transige ça
au gouvernement pour régler
le problème de manière
transparente et responsable
pour ne pas que des criminels
tombent sur ça par hasard.
- Le ministère de la santé
affirme qu'une erreur
de manipulation humaine
est à l'origine de la fuite
de ces données,
et que l'identité des citoyens
n'a pas été compromise.
Il ajoute que le ministère
a revu ses façons de procéder
afin d'éviter qu'une telle
situation se reproduise.
Mais l'ancien officier
en sécurité informatique
au ministère de la défense,
Steve Waterhouse, s'intéroge
tout de même sur les efforts
consacrés à la cybersécurité
dans l'éllaboration
de logiciels.
STEVE WATERHOUSE, expert en
sécurité informatique
- Si ça n'avait pas été
de la vigilance de certaines
personnes, il aurait pu y avoir
exploitation malicieuse
et, encore une fois,
- Si ça n'avait pas été
de la vigilance de certaines
personnes, il aurait pu y avoir
exploitation malicieuse
et, encore une fois,
ça aurait causé des torts
à la population.
- Les experts croient
donc qu'une intervention
gouvernementale est nécessaire
et qu'elle devrait prendre
la forme d'une loi obligeant
les organisations,
publiques ou privées,
à faire de la cybersécurité
une priorité dans l'élaboration
d'outils numériques.
Ici Kassandra Nadeau-Lamarche,
Radio-Canada, Québec.